ya basta provare a vedere questo
nuovissimo video di rocket league con i
lauri this nazionale io sono famiglie e
noi ci vediamo in partita let's go
allora signori il prima partita e paura
mi punto ogni volta quando così perché
negli horror che ho fatto per anni mi
spaventa talmente tanto tanto per me
parlare così come farà nuovamente solo
quando vado dal giornalaio è un casino
signore mi dia il giornale e lui sempre
devi abituarti primo gol poi scusa mi
turba scusa eco il compagno sbagliato
cioè con la bissata ok controllino da
passo ci sono stati solo se diamo gioco
di squadra di oggi esattamente quello
che avrei fatto io bravo come l'avrei
fatta io l'hai fatta anch'io ho detto
guarda voglio fare questa cosa non la
faccio perché voglio lasciare a lui
l'onore dell'ospite nel video è quindi
previsto il bacino finale fra st arriva
come si vota
bravi volta più o meno attenzione ok la
veduta bowyer io chi la vuole lui
nessuno non sito non si toglie mai pinto
l'appunto in avanti notevoli sco dalla
pompato strano che c'era paolo peccato
la partenza quale l'aria si gioca
peccato per il mio punteggio talmente
partita piano piano il mio conto e forte
e scusami non pensavo mai avevano dentro
con loro vabbè ma gliela facciamo perché
è giusto così all'inizio bisogna far
pareggi per poi far capire che siamo
superiori
ma se latini ferma io la tiro
all'incrocio destro vada tutto tuo
lo scherzo è questo caso bruttissima
cosa però adesso l'appunto nel mezzo
così giovane mamma mia
questo quando va bene va bene niente
no cosa è successo non ha seguito
l'azione ma cosa vuole ma cosa vuole
riscatto tumulti una cosa vuole entro
stranissimo pochettino leggerei prima di
roba fortino giusto tutta palle li volo
io l'ho col più semplice della storia ma
fa niente
ho visto una bella meta è ora sembra
importante farlo a 2 proprio lì i luoghi
prima fotocopia in all'incrocio destro
niente conta 22 ed heather ci sia capito
è mai uomini ma prima lei no prima lei
la prima lei con loro pacchettino è
invece no ma cosa leggo il pazzo io ho
sbagliato tutto tu hai segnato per un
bel passaggio era un bel passa esatto
perché qua volevo andare di temperare
troppo lontano vi è stato un passato da
camera il libro la camera ritiene natura
di mela ferma nella tengo lì e lì ha
spinto mano toccato una notizia
bellissima madonna e niente io dovuto
tenerla consigliere
ho mai fatto benissimo se riusciamo a
tutto il muro e la voce rimbalza verso
di te che incredibile io non vado mai
sul bur once prendo mezza volta
eccolo eccolo ha fatto lui ps più o meno
pallone liberos detto che cosa serissima
arriva non arriva arrivate arrivata
legate al di là quasi corse rai sera c'è
la bomba mandami è proprio lui
brave bellissimo passaggio è piaciuta
poi olivo al bus era pincio clip ma
tutta tua passavano a qualcosa dalla
prima passano a 4 stop pechino come lo
tra stato fatto bene molto bene
bellissimo bellissima ho detto che se lo
si vuole fare un rock a fuoco proprio
adatta allo stato dalla ceca dove invece
funzionato bene gigi va bene gigi
ragazzi madonna come era andato in
anticipo credibile poco e poi hanno
vinto loro sono anche compare anche non
c'era certo c'era c'era ma dovetti
l'altro dove sono ma con pato lui ho
segnato con lui io tre gol non ti prego
guarda lui tutta l'azione per favore
quale giallo oro giallo e fanno parte
dal rabbia il compagno va fatto da me ha
colpito la palla entrata no vabbè per
questo ha smerciato il joystick e nel
computer e gli tornati indietro intatto
torino ma per caso se per caso capito
non lo dico con anticipo tranquillità
ripasso la guarda tutta tua onesta
se il mio ti non avesse fatto cagare
sarebbe stato nelle palestre parlava da
prendere il bus al volo che non mi vuole
anticipare che il pazzo mutilati
ritenuti contrari ovvero guardalo tema
poi quando lo zio ma barbato lo zio
aspetto il sud come prof
il gol come prima d'ora posso io sono in
porta va bene come sia importo amico
luigi possono importa proprio time
buongiorno niente proprio zero
attenzione questa brutta
no niente non ho preso il turbo volevi
dove tu no voglio io chi lo vuole la
vuole lui ok lo spinge più dotato
smanaccia non aspettava ma quanto faccio
schifo ha raggiunto non era facile non
era facile ed entra
non lo sapevo ma sono molto mi
consentono a maiden
vabbè ma lo temevo un film da blocco
così affinché lo chiama la giunta si è
visto il peso di queste gol perfetto
tutto calcolato ragazzi che tiene sempre
la che ci provo modo più lento notereste
a bloccarla così ma gassman che madonna
che gol ma che noi no bravissimo
bravissimo in strisce bravissimo ben
parlato poi sempre a torino società e si
impalla sono vivono
beh noi pino tutto non centro aspetto il
passaggio tra su tutto o mio dio si darà
la trovo era troppo e va bene va bene
ciao amico
buona la pressione e io trasfo ancora io
trovo noi rosati un anticipo attenzione
però è lì il passaggio di che posso ben
altra slice e trust amica proprio devo
dirlo ma niente vicino stai tranquillo
tuttavia è fuori si sentiranno to be
nice
beh questa combattuta che ha visto i
quali ho visti dagli agguerriti cod
agguerritissimi normale non c'è monti
tenuto il sito letto sì sì subito con lo
stesso vincitore del recente i sì
champion 2 proprio lui che i ragazzi
anche il video di oggi è concluso
sappiate che io e lowry bis ci siamo
messi lì per decidere di farli fare un
improvement solo che plichi nel senso
che io sia arrivato a champion senza
meccaniche sostanzialmente perché non so
volare fare cose sono solo sono una
buona visione di gioco e per questo che
battono anche chi vola però se io
facessi queste cose sarebbe un livello
successivo quindi magari potrebbe
puntare anche al grand champion queste
cose qua quindi dalle sementi de
laurentiis ci impegneremo lui si
impegnerà via insegnarmi che sa fare
perché io a fare faccio schifo quindi la
sua pazienza dovrà essere abbastanza ora
però ci impegneremo a fare questo
next level ringrazio voi per aver visto
il video discrete rea che ha lasciato un
bel mi piace e non come sempre ci
vediamo
[Musica]